how have you been everybody good down
there and south you're you're doing well
man yeah
are you based in south florida still
down in fort lauderdale okay
yeah i am so uh you know what if if
we're gonna deal with coveted might as
well do it in the warmth
okay so um what's with the two of
distaste is that is that prevalent in
south florida
because they saw that he struggled or um
what is the general sense of dolphins
fandom as you
uh live down there and sense it jeff
yeah i don't i i think that there's
actually more patience
um locally than maybe it feels like
nationally
um i think there's a sense down here in
fact it's it's
interesting to me there's a pretty
pretty strong contingent
um of fans that when you bring up the
sean watson
and what they'd have to give up you know
to get him that get pretty defensive
uh for tua so i understand nationally
the narrative definitely
is that you know can he really handle it
the dolphin should upgrade
but but i do think that i sense that um
this is a group down here that kind of
saw enough potential to where they feel
like he deserves at least another year
to kind of grow into the hole yeah i
mean my gosh
i mean the guy the guy had his hip
reattached right i know i'm exaggerating
but then then then then he's drafted by
the team that wanted him all along
they they move him along pretty darn
fast
um he i guess what would be his high
water mark was it that game against kylo
murray where he was so dynamite on the
road
is that what it was or yes and no
question right
and and then you know let's give him a
shot give him a couple more weapons and
see how it goes i i i would think unless
deshaun watson strolls along then i i
would pull the trigger on that not
right you know that's just my two cents
so
i don't even think rich would be having
the conversation if not for the watching
um avail potential availability i don't
think it's a conversation
with you know the russell wilson stuff
like you don't see dolphins fans getting
up about that
the idea of a 25 year old elite
quarterback and desean watson being
potentially available
and seemingly having the ammunition to
be able to make it happen
i think is what creates that intrigue
but otherwise we would be saying you
know what it was his first year
he most by the way i mean towards the
end of the season
all of his wide receivers were hurt he
had no running backs
like he really wasn't working with very
much i
i i do understand both sides of it this
is an organization that has been a bit
snake bitten to say the least
you know watching ryan tan he'll get
comeback player of the year
while you're also trying to to develop
your your young quarterback you know
like there's a lot
there's a lot going on down here there's
a lot of uh a lot of angst that these
people have gone through when it comes
to that tv spot
and so uh what is the watson
situation best you can tell uh you know
my colleagues still at the nfl media
group
your former ones and weich and jim
trotter
had jaylen ramsey on their huddle and
flow podcast and they share an agent
and jalen's like i'm highly doubtful
he's never going to take another snap
for them again
uh where does that stand here at the end
of
um you know at the end of the first week
of march on the eve of a ton of cuts to
come with a
smaller cap and then the new league year
beginning where does that stand
jeff you know i was talking to an
executive uh
two days ago who was saying that that
they truly and this is an executive of a
quarterback needy team that
was essentially saying they truly do
believe that casario uh the gm
in houston is not taking phone calls
that he is
um remaining with his feet in the cement
now the uh caveat there is that this
person then says wait until a week
before the draft
so i think the expectation is that
they sense that houston has no reason to
jump at this point
that that the there's a belief that
watson will eventually be available
that he will wind up playing for another
team but that houston is
is merely trying to uh wait this thing
out whether for
leverage or you know public relations
reasons but
the one thing i think is important to
point out here
i find it fascinating like right now
there's there's a sense around the week
that russell wilson will not be
available
if russell wilson though suddenly does
become available things really
degenerate in seattle to the point where
he's on the market
to me houston starts to lose some
leverage because right now supply and
demand is watching
gets whatever they get whatever they
want for watson
but suddenly if the bears for instance
were to say
uh you know what if you won't take our
offer for watson we'll go off of the
same thing for russell
so suddenly that changes to me that is
the only
sense of urgency if i was nicerio that i
would have
in regards to when i should pull the
trigger on the watson trade
right but public relations i mean you
know again
this is this is unlike anything we've
ever seen
jeff we've seen a lot of on uh uh first
i agree from a 43 year old quarterback
after 20 years with one team
winning a super bowl and a pandemic with
a new one in just his first shot that's
that's for starters you know uh goff and
wentz
being traded um with big huge fat
contracts both of them gone so and and
two guys that
sign those big deals um under the new
construct which is still relatively new
with collective bargain agreement just
only you know less than 10 years old or
it turns his the first one that just
getting renewed turns 10 this year
so we've seen a lot of firsts right um
so i
i've never seen anything like this where
it's a 20
what he's 25 right 26 deshaun watson and
and he's got a huge fat contract that he
just signed a year ago
he says he doesn't want to play for the
team anymore and it's not contractual
it's not money it's prideful because of
who owns the team apparently or who the
owner has
brought on uh as a character coach to
run the team
and you know so so you've got you've got
that
um and then you've got on top of it
he's got the no trade clause so you've
got to be partners with him
that's right in this thing so they could
make this trade all they want and then
he could say yeah no
we're not doing that so they've got to
like run it up his flagpole
essentially and they've got to work
together to make it all work out
so the the cement and pr
aspect of it that this executive told
you jeff uh
includes sort of uh making
desean look like the malcontent at some
point when he
you know when an ota hits and he doesn't
show up you know what i mean like
when when off season workout program
starts he's supposed to be there and
he's not or if he is
then there's gonna be a microphone in
front of his face this is not just gonna
stay as quiet as it's gonna stay
you know i i i just i've never seen
anything like it i don't quite
understand it
when there are two teams in the afc east
that you could play off against each
other right and there's
tapper as well you're saying the bears
are in this like what could what
are they going to give them the lease to
to soldier field like what what
what do they have well so so
so so to your point i i i do not think
that
the pr spin changes i don't think that
the tide shifts to where desean is
suddenly
the one that gets blamed especially
given everything that has happened when
you look at
how many people have left the
organization from hopkins to
i mean even guys that you know texas
fans say bill o'brien yeah we
we did want to see him fire brian game
the gm who was largely unproven
amy paulsick who is a pr person widely
popular but probably to fans
not somebody that's all that well known
but but the sum of all of that
creates this dissension within the
organization to where it's not the tide
is not going to change
and desean watson will remain uh in
favor of
favorable light but to your point um
but when it comes to the the potential
suitors you know
a team like the bears the way it was
presented to me was
you've got uh gm and nicotheria who's
trying to build the organization right
so he's gonna covet future picks
more so than maybe um a gm that's on the
hot seat
whereas in chicago you got ryan pace who
if he doesn't get a quarterback he's
done
so there's a lot of people around the
league who think that compensation could
not just merely be
this year but future year first round
picks
because that's something that houston
would covet and that
um a team that desperately need the
quarterback
might not so uh i i think at the end of
the day
we i i don't know if it's chicago but i
think that we see
a situation where he is sent for a
mammoth package
that is all about future compensation
jeff darlington here on the rich eisen
show you said on get up this week that
the russell
wilson pete carroll relationship
reminds you of the brady belichick
relationship i'll give you the floor
here what do you mean by that what do
you mean by that
well in the funny thing is it's not
necessarily the relationship
that that people think they know of
belichick and brady of the last
year where a year ago there was a lot of
talk about
these guys need to go through kind of
the equivalent of marriage counseling
they needed to sit down
and hash it out there was this
expectation that the meeting was going
to happen
that mean never happened the
relationship was already dead
with pete carroll and russell wilson
that i think the comparison is more
like seven eight years ago belichick
brady when
it was never really all that great like
it was always this pretty cold
relationship between them but it worked
and they were able to weather some
storms
uh behind the scenes certainly not as
public as what we saw last year norris
public as what pete carroll and russell
wilson
are seemingly enduring right now but
seven or eight years ago when they were
going through this
they had someone in robert craft helping
to sort of mediate
i think that russell and pete are now in
that phase of their relationship
that's seven or eight years ago
relationship of tom brady and bill
belichick
if they can weather this if they can sit
down and figure this out they've got
plenty of years together
that they can still succeed my question
is do they have somebody that can help
mediate this
that can help both sides see
some compromise because paul allen late
the late paul allen
um he was pretty hands off even even
when he was
around with the team now it's not even
it's not even that
so i just my big hesitation about
whether pete carroll and russell wilson
can
get through this is whether or not they
have someone to help them do it it
should be there's a lot of egos involved
and i just i don't know well i've got
mclemore on in hour three should i ask
him
i mean we got you should ask him but i
would be very curious to see that
macklemore
macklemore is surprisingly that guy's
you know it's funny rich you want to
hear a funny story
i was uh remember that nfc championship
game in seattle
the place was absolutely rocking i'm on
the sideline waiting to do our post game
interview
mclemore's with his whole crew they're
playing macklemore over the speakers
and he drops his keys and he starts like
run out on the field his keys are
sitting there
they have to pick up his keys and like
chase down macklemore and be like
hey bro you dropped your keys he's like
thanks man
it was the most random running i've ever
had with someone of that stature and uh
i feel like he was appreciative i think
we're seeing a photograph of him
celebrating with russell wilson
after that very game we're seeing uh on
the screen right there but yeah
you know i i just uh i i i drop his name
just
not only uh promotionally but uh just in
a way to
to throw it into the next question like
so what would be
what is on the agenda list of this
marriage counseling like what
what what is there you know we we could
have
always sensed what was between brady and
belichick brady being like hey listen to
me a little bit more
and uh belichick saying i don't know
what his two cents would possibly be
but what what is what would be on the
agenda list here
that's why they're in counseling uh but
what so what what is the counseling here
between
pete and and russ what's on the list
here to go through
not not not that very different from
what you just cited
you know like hey man like you gotta i i
just want you to listen to me a little
bit more about this offensive line and
what we got going here and
you know and and trying to fix it you
know listen to to who what you think
about what i like about this offense
it's it's not that different
um from what brady was going through and
brady like russell
is a really good soldier the ultimate
soldier to be honest
so it's it's not like a malcontent i i
think that
a lot of times these organizations do
need to realize as
jason like deserves a lot of credit like
jason light last year
you know people wanted to be like oh
tom's running the show in tampa and it's
like why because he's made some
suggestions that jason white listened to
you know like is that it is obviously
a pretty thin line like you don't want
to all of a sudden just
allow your quarterback to to be
assistant gm
but if you have a longtime veteran who
is obviously successful
at their craft you know maybe it's worth
paying attention to them and i think
that that would be russell's argument
now belichick for instance we joke but
he was basically
no i'll handle it you go do your job
literally
do your job and that where on the
relationship
but again robert kraft was there at
times when it probably would have been
too fractured to continue to say no
tom is our quarterback he's sticking
around bill
make this work and they ultimately did i
again who's going to do that for pete
and russ
i i don't know that's that's my big
question
who is going to help mediate these egos
through this situation
to where there's some compromise on both
sides jeff darlington here on the rich
eisen show and while we're all focused
on the quarterback carousel
um free agency uh i'm wondering if
um the the the first that we mentioned
just a few minutes ago again
we've never seen quarterbacks uh
in the the current world where
quarterbacks are slotted in the draft
monetarily
we've never seen um a quarterback let
alone two
sign a monster contract earn it like
that was the con
that was the idea of the new collective
bargaining agreement instead of giving
all that money
sight unseen upon drafting let's see
what they can do for at least three four
years
and then now the teams are on the hook
for that generationally wealthy contract
we've never seen two quarterbacks sign
those big deals and then
fall out of favor one of them just kind
of fall apart in wence
and then another in golf fall out of
favor is that going to affect
the quarterback class that's kind of up
right now for
long-term deals mayfield lamar
josh allen uh those are the three as we
we uh
we're we're talking about right now is
that going to be a copycat sort of thing
situation here
the nfl so i think this is one of one of
the more fascinating
um narratives that sort of exists you
know if you're
if you're a bit of a football nerd you
know i don't know if everyday fans care
as much about this but
this whole option situation with these
quarterbacks to your point like
an organization wants to make the most
of a rookie a a quarterback on a rookie
deal
i mean talking about russell wilson like
when did he win the super bowl he's on
that rookie deal
so the question though is how do you
balance the line between
the wence golf situation and dak
prescott situation
because here we are hammering the
cowboys per early how how are they not
signing back
well the problem is they missed the
window had they signed them
going into that fourth year they
probably could have you know it might
have felt rich at the time but it would
have been
a a pretty normal contract for a guy who
continued to succeed
and on the other side of it though we
talked about extending too early
with wence like when signed that deal
we're like wait
what i didn't even know like i remember
when he signed that i was like wow i
had no idea that this was even like
close to where they would consider that
it was so early so there has to be a
balance
and it's such a tight rope that it
happened with kirk cousins
scott mcloone i remember the gm at the
time told me that
with cousins like we missed the window
it got to the point where he
outplayed what we could offer him and
what he was going to earn in free agency
we missed the window
it feels like the cowboys have missed
the window you gotta time it right
there is a tipping point and i don't
know what that is
it's it's you know each team's gonna
deal with it but there's a tipping point
with baker with lamar with josh
and you gotta time it right are they
gonna get it this year
are they gonna get it right now what do
you think
so i think that baker is not quite there
like i said that's a dangerous one um
i could see the bills doing you know
like like josh allen i think will be on
the earlier end
um but i don't get the sense that
there's any any significant talks for
instance with baker
yet and i would i would say that um
that's one of those dangerous ones man
because if he comes in and plays lights
out this season
all of a sudden did you miss the window
it's just it's such a tough game for
these gm staff to play well i mean lamar
i mean hasn't he shown
already i i i again you know i'm just
again wondering if wence and goff
have gotten these uh general managers a
little bit
sort of gun shy on putting something big
on the table probably
i mean think about lamar i mean lamar
mvp of the league but then you know on
the other side you're sitting there
saying
what you know you think about the
playoff situation
and i'm more than likely he's going to
get over that and grow and develop and
prove his
his value but if you're if you've seen
what happened with wence and
goff to a little bit of a different
degree to your point like
man it's gonna it's tough to pull the
trigger and you know that these
quarterbacks aren't
sitting there saying like i'm willing to
give you a discount to do it early
so it's just such a tight rope to walk
and
probably the biggest challenge i would i
would argue the biggest challenge
that a general manager has to face when
they draft a good quarterback last one
for you
uh i say this respectfully why isn't
drew brees retired yet
because we all thought he would or we're
all assuming
it's a little weird i was talking to
somebody in new orleans who said they're
just waiting on drew
um the bookkeeping is done you know i'm
sure you know that
his 25 million dollar salary has been
reduced to the minimum
um the bookkeeping says he's retired
basically
so i don't know if it's just something
where drew wants to wait it out to where
maybe
there can be a little bit more pomp and
circumstance to it you know i don't but
the the saints are just waiting on drew
and i think
um i mean they're acting behind the
scenes as if he's retired but
you know when we go see these videos
they've been pushing the sled
looking like he's getting ready for 2021
you know and
and what we've already described as a
wacky wacky off season
i think we're all sitting here saying
what what's exactly going on here
maybe uh maybe drew's got the bookkeeper
right uh maybe he's hopped the train in
chicago and he's got the bookkeeper just
like the untouchables
maybe he's found the bookkeeper and i
mean we'll never see
you know we'll put the bookkeeper on the
stand and we'll keep this thing going i
have no idea
you know i got to be honest like i
i root for chaos so
you're like didn't louis riddick say
that like let's keep it going it's
something to talk about
that's what he said yesterday oh my gosh
thanks for the call jeff really
appreciate it you'd be well we'll chat
soon
you got to see me at jeff jonathan on
twitter i follow him you should too
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here